uh for everyone this is uh lucy
solnier i hope i pronounced your name
right
um lucille is a machine learning
engineer at hugging face and she
develops and supports the use of open
source tools
she's also actively involved in many of
the research projects in the field of
nlp such as a really cool project about
collaborative training so this is where
you try to basically train like a
transformer from scratch
distributed across multiple machines in
the world so people share their kind of
compute for this it's a really cool
project you should check out
and we have it on the blog
and she's also heavily involved in the
big science project which you may have
heard about this is a one-year kind of
research endeavor to try and train a
very large language model that is kind
of like gpt3
but hopefully with a lot more insight
into how this model works
and today she's going to explain to us
how to get our own tokenizer with
hugging face transformers and
hugging face tokenizers libraries
so thanks lucille and we'll see you for
the questions
hello everyone i'm really happy to be
with you today for the launch of part
two of our course
what i wanted to propose to you today is
to see how you can get your own
tokenizer with the transformers on
tokenizer's orginface libraries
what i'm going to say next will be
mostly for the purpose of using training
a language model
but be aware that you can absolutely
meet tokenizers in other contexts
so
what is a tokenizer
a tokenizer is a component located
between
the textual data and the language model
it is in charge of preparing the data in
other words putting the data in the
format expected by the language model
more specifically a tokenizer
is responsible for dividing
the text into sequence of smaller units
called tokens
the big point is
that this tokenizer is coupled with a
vocabulary that maps each token with a
unique number
in this way the tokenizer transform a
row text into a sequence of numbers
we do that because a language model is a
function that can only take numbers as
input
the tokenizer is is thus really designed
and trained to be the best adapted to
the data on the language model
on this apply to
all the sub operations included in the
tokenizer from
normalization to post processing
so when you want to train a language
model you will ask yourself the question
what should i do with the tokenizer
the first possibility is that there is
already a train tokenizer that fits
your needs very well and in this case
the question is quickly solved
on the other hand if you do not find
such tokenizer you can perhaps find a
tokenizer
whose design is appropriate to you but
that you will need to adapt to your data
in other words only to retrain it
or you perhaps want to completely design
your own tokenizer on training in your
data this is the third case showed here
the good news is that the game face
libraries have put everything in place
so that you can do everything whether
you are in the first case the second
phase or the third case
the course that was just released has a
very detailed chapter on tokenizers and
will allow you to really understand
everything about tokenizer on how to get
your home organizer
so i thought it might be interesting to
show you another resource
that show use on a new you know simple
example
all you could do if you are in the case
two or three just discussed before
this should give you a little bit of an
appetizer before you start the course
so i'm going to leave this presentation
and move on to the notebook
you may already know them but you can
find in the transformer repository a
series of notebooks that explain concept
or or how to perform several tasks
on among them
you can find one called try new
tokenizer
to save some time i already
or download it
to run it locally
a little extra information as
interesting to do it locally
so here
you will need to have installed the data
set on transformers packages
with
one extra dependency which is sentence
piece
so you can see here that i have
everything installed before
then whether it's for case two or three
that we just discussed before you will
need to train a tokenizer model and so
for that we you will need some data
if you plan to train a language model
afterwards you just need to take a
subpart of your training data
for this example we will still need data
and we will take the wiki text tool
we can load it directly with the dataset
library
which allow us to consult it very easily
we can see it's composed of 36 000 text
we can also look at
the first example
or even the first five
what we need next is an iterator on our
data so we are going to do that right
now
you can see with this cell that is a
simple way to do it but it's not very
suitable because it lost everything in
memory
so it's better to use the battery
literature method defined just below
we will now see the solution to the
situation 2 of earlier that is to say
that you have found a fast organizer
whose design suits you but not its
training
in this notebook we will say that the
design that suits us is the one of gpt2
so we load this tokenizer
and we check that it's really a fast
organizer
on that we just have to use the train
new from interactive method to train it
again on our data
after it's trained we can see what it
gives on our data set
and that's all
the
new tokenizer is ready so maybe it's a
good idea to save it
and we can even send it directly to the
app to get it from everywhere and share
it with other people
so if you want to do that
you just need to run this cell
and fill in your again fast credentials
okay and you will also need um
to have git large files to write
installed
so if you don't you can do it by
uncommenting this line
and there you go
you can load it on the app
after that very easily you can check
with this line if you can retrieve it so
here is the case
and that's all
the case 2 is finished
so now we can
we can do we can see how we can do when
we really want to make a complete
tokenizer from scratch
on for that we will use the tokenizers
library
for this example we will remake the
tokenizer of bert
but you can really imagine everything
so to start
we'll initialize a tokenizer with a
model of our choice belt uses wordpiece
so we will use wordpiece here too
if you remember my little diagram at the
beginning of this talk
there are also other operations that we
can define in our tokenizer
the first one is the normalization
so we can use directly the birth
normalizer
or we could redefine the sequence of
normalizer it's the same
well it's almost the same you can check
at the course to understand what could
be missing here
then we can define the pre-organization
operation
we can't
we can take the opportunity to
see
the results on an example
so here you can see that the words have
been
separated from each other
and now
that we have defined all the operations
of stream of the model we can train the
model
so
to train wordpiece there are two
arguments that are particularly
important
there is the special
tokens
and
the vocab sides
in the special tokens we have to list
all the special tokens that we want
to add to our vocabulary
the vocab cells will define the final
size of the vocabulary
that we want at the end of the training
so we launch a training
once it's finished we can define the
operations that follow the model
so
the next operation is the
post-processing
to define our post-processing we need to
know the idea of two special tokens that
we want to add to our sequences
so indeed birds need to add the class
token at the beginning of each example
on the separation token between two
sentences and at the end of each example
so once
we have retrieved them
we can
add them in our template
processor
we can also indicate that the opal
should not contain only the sequence of
ids corresponding to the tokens but also
another sequence
indicating the type of each i uh each
token
here we will indicate that as a tokens
belonging to the first sentence should
be linked with a type fd of zero
or 1 otherwise
um
so let's look um
at what it gives
on an example
we can
see here as a
result in tokens and we can see that the
cluster can on the septuccans have been
added to the final sequence of the case
we can also look at the type ids and the
tokens belonging to the first sequence
are indeed linked to 0
or 1 otherwise
finally to finish our design we have to
tell the decoders that we have used a
wordpiece model
on that we should gather the tokens
started with two hashtags with the
previous document
so at this point we have finished
designing our organizer and to be able
to use it with a language model we can
load it into a tokenizer fast from the
transformers library
and that's it it's finished you have a
tokenizer which is ready to be used
so after that you can see that the
notebook shows um another example
even another one
so don't hesitate to test it yourself
of course in the stroke i didn't have
the time to deal with everything but i
could simply give you an overview of
what you can do with transformers on
tokenizer's libraries
i said at the beginning of this talk
the part two of the course as a wall
chapter dedicated to the tokenizer
and i really hope that you could find a
lot of useful information there
in order to
get really your own token either
i suggest that we use the remaining time
for any question you might have
welcome back
and thank you very much for that really
nice look this is it it's very
informative and it's um cool to see the
kind of inner workings of a tokenizer
so we have a couple of questions um i
think you kind of mentioned this a bit
in the talk um but it'd be nice to just
maybe expand a bit on it so the first
question is
when should i train a tokenizer from
scratch
and why can't i just always use one from
the hanging face hub
so you will have more information in the
course about this
question in particular
but the tokenizer is really something
that you need to adapt it both to your
data on your model so um you can't use
for example a tokenizer which is not
formatted for your model and you will
see that some tokenizer
had additional special tokens so um for
example so you have to be careful about
what it's added with the tokenizer
um but uh you also need to be adapted to
the data um for example you can try
different tokenizer on your data and if
you saw that some splitting is
really weird um the text is click on
really a lot a lot a lot of tokens
might not be
really fitted to your data um
yes i think the best test to do is to
test an english tokenizer there is a lot
of english mechanism on the app and test
it on a really different language like
for example indie and you will see that
it's not the best it's the best fit you
can find
maybe just to ask then a follow-up
question is you said okay suppose i have
a tokenizer that is not really well
adapted to my data set then it will
typically chop it up into like you know
many sub tokens why should i worry about
this what's the kind of problem with
that
and the first one is um you can see with
a lot of language model you have
a second length
of a limited length
so for example bert's it's a
on twelve
on the most you can find is 248
and so if you take too much
tokens to say not much you will at the
end not have a lot of context uh to give
to your models and it's really uh
something which is great with the
transformer models it's really to use
them as much as context as we can
in our invention layer so that's why it
can be problematic
awesome and i think another thing that
i've experienced is that um if you have
very long sequences then you actually
also get penalized because attention is
usually you know a kind of slow
computation so you kind of get two
problems you get one is like you don't
get enough information and two
your training is slower
so this actually raises
another question which is kind of this
was for me actually kind of surprising
the first time i learned about
tokenization so people say oh you know
you train the tokenizer with bur and i
think this is quite a different beast so
maybe you'd like to tell us a little bit
about what that what that means
yes that's a very very relevant question
um and yes we we are talking about
training at organizer but we don't train
the tokenizer in the same way we train
models um a tokenizer is much it's it's
more like a statistical learning uh but
we need to do some computation over uh
our training data set in order to
extract uh some data
that the token as a tokenizer need to
use a two-to-three sentence so for most
of the tokenizer a tokenizer will need
to learn a vocabulary which is a list of
token that he knows
awesome thanks that's really informative
we have a question now from alexia i'll
just put it up here
and they ask
how would you use special tokens to
introduce more complicated structures of
the data entries for example if every
entry is a dialogue then each utterance
is often separated by an end of sequence
token
i'm not sure to get exactly where the
question is is it really
a technical question
um
yeah my understanding of the question
was is like
we know that we have these special
tokens in all these tokenizers like for
example in bert there's the cls token or
the sep token
and um this is kind of a choice by you
know the designers of the models how
they want to encode some information
that's like sort of special to indicate
you know sentence structure or whatever
so the question is like if you're doing
something like biology or law or
something could special tokens help in
that context
uh
in the sense yes i think they can
definitely help
i'm
sorry i don't have i think a really uh
a good advice to give on how to use the
special tokens but yes you can
definitely leverage special seconds in
order to tell the model that
between these two special tokens
it's a question between these two
special tokens it's the answer you can
really uh use the special frequency
okay
the best way to do it technically
is to
put them in the template processor part
of your tokenizer from the tokenizers
library
awesome
yeah and this is actually a kind of
related problem so
when you work in industry you often have
like a domain that is quite different
from say wikipedia which is where bert
and all these other models are trained
on and so you get this kind of outer
vocab uh problem where a token maybe
doesn't belong
in the vocabulary of the organizer i was
just wondering like how do you how do
you think about this problem and are
there some good strategies that we can
use to deal with it
that's a really good question too um one
solution to the out of vocabulary
problem is to use
the bike level uh tokenizer so what
we'll do about cable tokenizer is like
the very fundamental unit you will use
it's a byte and we only have 258
values for bytes so it can define we can
definitely store all the values of a
byte in our vocabulary
on uh doing that we will be able to
tokenize any new text we can fill
afterwards
um there is also another solution
proposed to this problem but it's really
more at the stage of research i would
say it's really token either so based um
at the
at the unit level so the bite you have
by t5 for example
but that's more really
recent token either and it's not the
more common that we can find for our
language model
cool thank you very much that's a really
useful tip
maybe one last question is is more
personal so could you tell us a little
bit about what work you do in the big
science project
yeah sure
so
i will not have the time to really give
you the whole um
um view over what big science is but
it's really a research project project
with seven england researchers so to
organize everything these researchers
are
working together in working groups so
i'm personally part of
two of these working groups
for one i'm mainly helping on the
engineering side so really running big
experience on the big one on a really
big super computer which called chanza
and with another working group and we're
working
on great design and research sites and
we are already a
studying one question in order to see if
we can improve in a way uh the training
of log wage models and give them more
capabilities
cool thank you
and
i think we have a minute left so maybe
i'll ask you one last question what is
your favorite tokenization algorithm and
why
i think the using gremlin
i like
the probabilistic approach
great
thank you thank you
yeah thanks a lot for your talk and your
other answers to the questions
bye